this video is sponsored by private
internet access this video is not
sponsored by the Hungarian Railways in
fact this video contains a substantial
rent directed against them God they suck
in July 2023 I had a really cool idea
namely to travel from Germany to the
north of the Czech Republic by train
outside the Prague Berlin Main Line This
is a feat nobody has attempted for
almost a century so I figured the task
is up to me now having written my will
beforehand I hit it from Leipzig to a
town called Freiburg where my train
would depart towards the Czech border
and there it was the shinkansen of
Saxony actually it's totally regular
shuttle and it's a pretty good train for
Countryside operations it's small but
scalable its low floor has AC no
complaints there you can even see into
the driver's cabin which is cool it was
so far so good on my doomed Journey to
the Czech Republic it was pretty
hilarious how the smallest train was
flooring it through the forest so kudos
to Germany the tracks are mostly in
order for those of you interested this
is the rb83 from Freiburg the whole toe
so yeah we're going to hold so right on
the Czech border there we go getting
close this does look like a wholesale to
me and we're here better get off now
since according to the sign this train
will continue on to nicht Einstein again
and that isn't somewhere you want to be
alright so it's time to get on the train
to the Czech Republic
alright I guess it's going from over
there behind those trees a little bit
further on
oh I can feel the dramatic tension
building and for good reason searching
for my train connection just behind the
tree line in the ditch
there it was
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
well there's my problem the line has a
significant missing section between the
stations holds Howe and Moldova
vikrishni horak a good eight kilometers
of track is missing what the [__] is
this piece of [__] but the thing is I
still have a train to catch on the check
side so better get going the free state
of sex in it if you want to go by train
[__] you get a card idiot global warming
isn't real to be fair there have been
increasing talks about restoring this
line and none of the two sides Zach said
and usted ski cry oppose it only you
need to get funding from somewhere how
and when this will be done is unclear in
the meantime it's jungle diving for
passengers though there have been some
good precedents already a bit to the
east around Dresden a few years ago they
plugged a similar Gap in the track on
the border enabling the start of the u28
local line and it has been popular both
with locals and tourists since then
there is also the Yuan geord against
which is also okay but that would be too
much of a detour plus I came here to
suffer and to chew bubble gum and I'm
all out of gown so let's get on with my
low budget German reenactment of Tropic
Thunder by the way as I said this video
also includes a substantial about the
Hungarian Railways and the trash fire
they call Euro City service in this area
so look forward to that in a bit in the
meantime I gotta move fast through this
Forest as I've seen some squirrels
around and squirrels just like cats are
controlled by government satellites as
we all know to prevent the sex on deep
state from using the squirrels to view
your browsing history I recommend using
private Access VPN to do just that for
the two of you who don't yet know what a
VPN or a virtual private network is it's
a service that hides your IP address and
keeps your connection safe via an
encrypted tunnel your device is on
average Trends with a lot of information
about you which can become accessible to
various other parties on the way that's
where private internet access comes in
shielding you from the eyes of isps
State censorship attempts and various
other malicious actors it also helps you
bypass websites region blocks looking at
you Instagram threads they are the
world's most transparent VPN provider
with over 30 million downloads not
recording or storing any user data
apparently this was also proven in court
multiple times and Via a Delaware audit
private internet access also comes with
additional benefits it works with all
major streaming websites so if you
wanted to watch British TV for some
reason like top gear but it's blocked in
your country well now you can watch it
by switching to a US server funny enough
oh and the service also boasts the rare
feature of P2P file sharing support
private internet access is available on
all platforms Windows Mac Linux and so
on and you can protect an unlimited
number of devices at the same time with
a single subscription I especially find
such a VPN service useful when using
public Wi-Fi networks on longer train
trips use my link in the description and
get 83 of private internet access for a
mere two dollars and three cents per
month in addition you'll also get four
months free signing up is risk free as
you'll have a 30-day money-back
guarantee and 24 7 customer support in
case you're having trouble big thanks to
private internet access for sponsoring
today's video and now make to the forest
aside from the whole catastrophic lack
of engineering strategy for cross-border
real traffic the area is quite nice
though on the German side rather
underdeveloped funny enough as you're
making your way into clearing that used
to be the train track you can listen to
the sounds of traffic on the brand new
road parallel to you the surroundings
really are picked to risk imagine a
Switzerland style panoramic train
traveling here I'm Dreaming Of course on
both sides of the border the there are
way too many conservative Boomers in
government whose ass cheeks are 70 BMW
seat leather at this point through
Decades of pressure as Moses next to the
trail parts of the old rails are dug
into the ground to Mark The Edge as if
to spite me hey look even the old rail
bridge is still here no rail on it
though makes sense as the company BMW
x5s and Mercedes g-classes cannot travel
on Rails so rebuilding it would be
practically useless oh and there's also
a creek I just wanted to show you it
looks nice by the way when I'm standing
still that wobbling is my heart rate
when not recording I'm going at a very
fast pace because I have a train to
catch on the other end of a goddamn
hiking path here's the German check
border have fun hiking in the Bohemian
Ormond just [__] you I'm hiking here
against my will just build a [__]
train here's a beautiful Creek to us
watch my negative feelings look how it
flows and just like how taxpayer's money
flows into pointless Highway projects by
the [__] real network is falling
apart in front of her okay it's time to
move on on the check side there is an
actual pave cycle path which is neat
Germany could build one as well but SUVs
wouldn't fit on it so it would be
pointless the area is unique as it
hasn't really changed over the centuries
providing a cool time window for us now
entering the village of moldaba a
settlement of like 15 houses up in the
mountains which still has better public
transit than Los Angeles after a half an
hour March I finally reached the center
there's the German border again and of
course the obligatory alcohol and
cigarette stores for Boomers I made it
earlier than I thought I still had about
40 minutes till my train so I spent my
time in the local cultural center after
some self-education once I felt smart
enough I moved over to the station
finally I reached my connecting train
and it all it took was two hours of
jungle diving time to take this former
Deutsche ban series 628 diesel multiple
unit first produced in 1974 overhauled
and operated by Gabe train I actually
have no complaints here considering the
circumstances the train has AC Wi-Fi and
power sockets also an LCD information
Screen through the overhaul they get out
pretty much everything they could out of
this classic set also the toilets are
just aesthetic
and off we go at this point my task is
to get back into Germany so I need to
take this train through the mountains
down into the Flatlands where I can
hopefully reach the Czech main line
along the mountain track time was frozen
in the early 1900s so the track
infrastructure hence the incredible
speed the train produces despite the
century old infrastructure the area has
not been abandoned the track on the
check side was reinforced last year so
their clear accounting with service here
after some more near moxby travel I
finally reached the Czech local line
which connects into the main line it is
newly renovated with some work still
ongoing for track replacement a speed
increase of up to 135 kilometers for
local trains it's need to be in a
country that takes its rail network
seriously local service is operated for
now with overhauled s-bound cars with a
converted control car at the front
nicknamed golfer this is a great example
of how to make the most of what you have
even if you don't have swiss level
resources and now on to ustina Club M
where I hope to catch something towards
Germany currently we're going on one
track as the other one hasn't been put
down yet checks tend to give their real
administration at all of [__] but works
are constantly ongoing and there is a
mostly clear strategy as to what the
hell they want around accomplish and
like my dear home country Hungary oh
[__] this is the foreshadowing I guess
at the ustina Alabama station I got off
in hopes of Adventure Germany only
little did I know it was a Hungarian
Railways hero City sporting the
so-called Intercity plus cars the stupid
ass goddamn Intercity plus cars that are
the reason why we can't have nice things
okay so let me explain so the Austrian
Railways we all know them we all like
them quality Rolling Stock Rock Solid
strategy Sky High punctuality if
Switzerland is the real Mecca of the
world Austria is a very close second in
the early 2000s austrians looked at
their distant strange lead still quite
impressive even then and thought how
could we make this even better the bulk
of their Fleet were the well-known grad
simmering Euro City cars these things
were built in the 70s 80s and 90s and
turned out so well that other central
European rail operators couldn't stop
buying them secondhand the hungarians
run them the Czech Railways run them
regular jet runs them the grads similar
in Euro City cores or the heroine of
central European carriers why did the
austrians sell these if they were so
good because they knew better they could
have easily kept them and maintain their
still very high quality service for 30
more years but instead they decided to
fundamentally improve and innovate their
service the railjet program was launched
which instantly became their world
famous massively popular Flagship
product so what's so good about them
each train has 7 to 9 cores that are
permanently coupled this means the
vestibules open into each other and you
can walk from one end of the train to
the other without having to climb
through Dark Cloud gangways and have to
open 8 000 sliding double doors on the
way half of which aren't functioning
because of this the trade is more
spacious quiet and less prone to
electrical defects as the cables between
the cars aren't plugged and unplugged
constantly as cars don't need to be
switched the last car is a control car
enabling much faster turnaround times
without the need to unhook the
locomotive when changing direction sets
are capable of 230 kilometers per hour
and are pulled exclusively by Siemens
hero sprinters every time you travel by
railjet you know exactly which part of
the train is where and what level of
service you can expect as every train is
uniformly put together and equipped on
the inside the railjet service is a
[__] Masterpiece it represents the
absolute Pico regular no high speed
speed distance real traffic in Europe
[__] the ic4 [__] the pandolino it's all
about the rail jet they're so good the
check Railways is bulk ordering them and
even Amtrak can't help but Aid them with
their new Arrow sets and that's not all
a new generation of rail Jets is already
on the way Double Decker electric
multiple units are basically souped up
inner Stitch toddler kisses level
boarding Superior rate of acceleration
and deceleration 200 kilometers per hour
top speed these things are the new gold
[__] standard for below high speed
distance rail travel coming to you in
so this is what the austrians are up to
where this context in mind now we can
start talking about the Hungarian
Railways Inner City Plus
Once Upon a Time like 15 years ago
government officials together with the
Hungarian Railways leadership looked at
the state of the Hungarian Railway half
a century of Rolling Stock
infrastructure falling apart complete
lack of vision strategy and funding
constant breakdowns General chaos they
saw all that and decided they needed
a Hungarian milled passenger car the
vision was that they needed a
hungarian-made passenger car the
strategy was that they needed a
hungarian-made passenger car and the
goal was that they needed a
hungarian-made passenger car how will
they use it what service do they want to
provide with it and where what's the
overarching concept this new core will
be a part of who knows we'll just figure
it out as we go along does the Intercity
plus project was born the first two
prototypes were presented in 2013 five
years after the first villagers went
into operation then it was four more
years till mass production started 500
cards were supposed to be built of which
they managed 92 till funding was cut the
cards were built in Hungarian Railways
maintenance Workshop which was pretty
remarkable considering the workshop had
a significant shortage of repair
capacity and employees but they managed
to build IC plus cars by not overhauling
existing cars the end results the
railways best [__] their highest quality
Spanish cafeter City cars were rotting
on Side Tracks for years as a massive
car deficit plagued the entire Hungarian
rail system at the same time and for
what see generally in real passenger
traffic there are three types of trains
you can run classic sets that's
locomotive plus Passenger cars Push Pull
sets that's locomotive plus Passenger
cars plus a control car and there are
also multiple units push pulls are
superior to Classic sets because it can
change direction without having to
unhook the locomotive so it can go
around the set and then having to
re-hook it on the other side the driver
just walks over to the control car from
where they can remotely control the
locomotive in the back problem solved
this provides massive Savings in time
money and labor and then there are
multiple units which are superior to
both classic and push-pull sets they
have multiple smaller Motors that can
accelerate the train far better these
vastly Superior Dynamics come in very
handy when trying to work down delays
also they are low floor and can have
more doors on them which significantly
speeds up passenger exchange at stations
of these three categories the rear
jetted in the second though it's closer
to multiple units as it's permanently
coupled the Intercity plus however is
just a reproduction of the classic set
way to trap your Railway in the 1960s
permanently by reproducing offsolute
Solutions no not even the 1960s the
Hungarian Railways has been operating
its bddf control cars since 1963
designed to work together with their
Workhorse v43 locomotives in Suburban
traffic half a century later when
producing brand new distance Rolling
Stock they somehow forget a lesson they
already figured out shortly after World
War II the IC plus scores themselves are
of generally poor quality here are the
issues I documented just in one
vestibular one car after standing there
for two minutes the speaker is
misaligned the screen is falling off the
ceiling panel is about to fall down that
white wall panel's edges are highlighted
with Grime far better than the most
artisanally made Warhammer TOA Empire
miniature and otherwise it seems like no
two panels were fitted together
correctly but the biggest crime against
Unity was that they didn't just stop at
producing low quality new cars oh no
their best highest quality cafeter City
cars also got the IC plus treatment
turning their best most well-designed
golden age of rail Interiors into
something out of a cheap Countryside bus
this includes their beautiful red and
gold restaurant cars which now look like
Village buffets
I've actually visited the restaurant car
on the train back to Germany I ordered a
beer and some food but service was so
chaotic I only ever got my beer of the
two waiters one just sat around looking
at us while the other barely spoke
English it wasn't a problem for me of
course we spoke Hungarian but taking
other passengers orders in broken
English was an excruciatingly slow
ordeal as an extra the waiter did not
note down which table ordered what so
every time something was done he toured
around the entire car food in hand
trying his best to describe what he was
holding in broken English hoping someone
would recognize that order I waved him
down told him to forget my food order
because it's been an hour already and
I'm getting off in 10 minutes I paid
which consisted of him plopping down the
car terminal on my table and then
immediately leaving afterwards I went to
the toilet where there was no liquid
soap as usual thankfully the Hungarian
Railways always put an extra block of
soap in each bathroom as a standard but
these cars were designed with the
assumption that their operator is
capable of the Herculean task of
refilling the liquid so so the bathrooms
don't have a block soap holder because
of this Railway workers just throw the
soap into the sink for you to fish it
out but here creative passengers wanted
some hand wipes stuck a fistful on the
windowsill and embedded the soap into it
as a makeshift soap holder isn't that
great on the wall opposite to the sink
there was a coat hanger which in my
opinion represents the attitude and
current state of the Hungarian State
Railways better than a thousand page
essay could at some point the goat
hanger fell off and someone tagged the
wall under it so in the maintenance
Depot they screwed it back skewed with
two different types of screw and without
cleaning the tank from under it first
what an excellent representation of
their whole operation a tiny tip of a
massive Iceberg of [__] and this
was my rent about the Hungarian Railways
once I got off the training Dresden the
rest of the trip was fine DB has a
decent service to Leipzig using
Bombardier Italian electric multiple
units so to sum up the Hungarian Railway
suck ass and I can't wait for the hotel
mode of a gap closure to happen so that
passengers don't have to hike 2 hours in
a forest to catch their connection the
Jack Railways they deserve praise
they've been doing plenty of neat stuff
lately only they should stop giving
every new train set a new name oh and
their track numbering system makes zero
sense but otherwise impressive work good
for them alright that's the end of this
video it was quite the roller coaster
but I hope you had fun watching it
otherwise thank you for watching and do
consider supporting me on patreon if you
like my content and I'll be seeing you
next time
[Music]
foreign